há dois anos atrás o lancei meu primeiro
livro ele se chamava modo imita a vida e
ele tinha como principal premissa que o
processo de construção de uma marca o
processo de construção da nossa
identidade da gente enquanto ser humano
ele passa por um processo de observação
do mundo exterior e do mundo interior e
que é na verdade e na enfim nuno genuíno
desse cruzamento dessa nossa observação
conquistar fora e conquistar dentro que
surgem marcas inspiradoras pessoas
inspiradoras líderes é e à inovação e à
criatividade tudo isso que a gente
acabou de ver aqui e aí eu termino esse
livro é falando que esse nosso olhar
para o mundo ultimamente ele parece
estar um pouco cansado é um pouco triste
um pouco pessimista é um pouco frio
talvez distante e não à toa a gente
tenha é tanta gente falando sobre
mudança necessidade de mudança e tanta
coisa acontecendo diante dos nossos
olhos
e a gente tem me continuando fazendo as
coisas como a gente fazia muito tempo
atrás é e aí quando eu comecei a
escrever o meu segundo livro eu comecei
a relacionar todas essas coisas que eu
senti que mudaram ao longo do tempo
essas coisas todas que eu vi se
transformando diante dos meus olhos
e aí eu cheguei à conclusão que muito
mais do que o momento é de transformação
é o de transição é ou de reinvenção um
momento que a gente está vivendo agora
ele é um momento crítico e ele é um
momento de fim ele é o momento de fim de
ciclo né e é como se tudo que a gente
conheceu tudo que a gente tivesse vivido
até agora precisava chegar no fim pra
que a gente crie um novo pra que a gente
crie uma nova realidade é esse olhar que
falta pra gente parece a gente é ou não
percebe ou fingir que nunca vê ea gente
segue com modelos antigos com formatos
antigos sem pensar em todas as novas
coisas que aconteceram se a gente parar
para lembrar é o que existia no mundo
desde que a gente nasceu a tudo é assim
é não existe mais hoje né todos os
formatos todos os modelos tudo o que que
existia quando a gente era pequeno hoje
ou é completamente diferente ou perdeu
todo o sentido como por exemplo telefone
que eu acredito que alguns de vocês é
conheçam né é 11 nem me lembro disso
teletrim eu lembro quando comer
trabalhar que a gente recebia a mensagem
corria por ele ama tava ficha ligava era
uma loucura né em menos de dez anos em
menos de uma década o iphone surgiu a
internet surgiu e mudou completamente a
nossa vida mudou completamente todas as
nossas relações
né a relação da gente se divertir então
a forma como a gente se diverte hoje é
totalmente diferente da forma como a
gente fazia antes é a forma de a gente
ver filme a forma da gente namorar então
hoje a gente conhece brigas e para
terminar tudo pelo telefone é pelo menos
comigo foi assim e é e e hoje é tudo
isso acaba sendo muito transformado tudo
o que acontece na nossa vida acaba sendo
muito transformado por conta da internet
e da tecnologia né e isso é muito legal
como xangai e falou no primeiro bloco né
como também pode ser muito difícil muito
diferente né ou muito desafiador a forma
como a gente estuda hoje mudou
completamente o precisa mudar não à toa
a gente tem um terço de evasão das
escolas das faculdades de todo mundo que
ingressa é o formato de trabalho mudaram
ou eles precisam mudar ea gente vive
sempre um choque de realidade querendo
reproduzir modelos antigos fazer a
pessoa sair de casa tem um trânsito de
duas horas para chegar num lugar ficar
oito horas trancado trabalhando quando
existem mil novos formatos mil novas
possibilidade de se fazer isso né e
todas as indústrias começaram a sofrer é
é por não se adaptar ou por não entender
essa dificuldade ou essa diferença então
a gente viu o que aconteceu com a
fotografia que a gente teve acesso a
impressora a gente começou a imprimir as
fotos em casa e aí a gente quebrou a
kodak a fugir hoje a gente é tão louco
que a gente não imprime mais nada fica
tudo guardado no celular nem e isso é o
que vai acontecendo com o mundo na
indústria fonográfica hoje passa por um
grande momento de transformação a
indústria da moda também a e não só as
indústrias mas o capitalismo como um
todo hoje começa a ser questionado e as
pessoas começam a aquecer e é que aquele
seja de um jeito diferente as pessoas
começam a entender que o dinheiro não
tem mais a ver com o sucesso que é que o
sucesso de uma empresa não está ligado
somente o faturamento que o sucesso de
um profissional não está somente ligado
à conta ele ganha né e com isso novos
modelos começam a surgir muita briga
muita crise muita luta é de quem está
querendo fazer um novo que ainda está
preso não antes
só que fora toda essa questão filosófica
né e essa brincadeira essa comparação
com o fim do mundo é hoje acredito que
vocês saibam neo pelo menos desde a
eco-92 tem gente gritando e falando
sobre isso é a gente está na iminência
de realmente o fim do nosso mundo é o
fim da nossa espécie
pelo estilo de vida que a gente sabe tou
levar pela nossa dependência do petróleo
dos recursos naturais e pela a
aceleração do tempo pela nossa vontade
de forçar o tempo né pra ter mais
dinheiro para fazer mais para produzir
mais e isso acabou criando mais crise
mais sofrimento como xangai também falou
e mais necessidade de mudança mais
necessidade de transformação mas a gente
continua naquele modelo antigo e há
gente com a cabeça antiga querendo
resolver os problemas querendo é fazer
novas coisas e aí alguns dados de
algumas coisas que aconteceram enquanto
a gente estava trabalhando vendo
televisão ou correndo atrás do nosso
rabo 90% dos mamíferos foram extintos
95% da população marinha foi extinta a
75% da área de florestas foi devastada
40% do nosso solo foi desertificação 40%
da camada do árctico derreteu a
temperatura do planeta aumentou quase um
grau e se aumentar mais um talvez a
gente não consiga sobreviver
uma criança morre de fome a cada cinco
segundos no mundo 5 mil pessoas morrem
por dia com água contaminada
um bilhão de pessoas não têm acesso à
água pura e 2,8 milhões de pessoas têm
acesso restrito à água e daqui pra
frente o cenário ele é cada vez pior a
ladeira abaixo ea gente não pára pra
pensar nisso a gente não pára pra
entender o que a gente faz e como o que
a gente faz impacta nisso impacta é é
pode impactar em transformação e o
quanto a gente tem responsabilidade em
tudo isso que aconteceu
pelo estilo de vida pelo estilo de vida
que a gente viveu até hoje que a gente
levou o que me faz pensar que a moda
também chega num momento de crise num
momento de fim de ciclo a moda como a
gente conhecer o que a gente aprendeu a
fazer hoje perdeu bastante sentido
comprar vender roupa é vender qualquer
coisa hoje né passou a fazer muito pouco
sentido diante do
poucas pessoas chorando por dinheiro o
tempo que elas têm para conquistar
aquele dinheiro mas mesmo assim ducha da
moda continua querendo vender roupa para
quem não precisa eu amo esse é esse
trabalho do montante que apesar de não
ter nada a ver com a moda é pra mim e
reflete muito o cenário que a gente vive
hoje é que a gente continua tentando
fazer roupas e vender roupas para
pessoas que não precisam de roupas né
se vocês olharem primários vocês eu
acredito que eles têm lá 80% de coisas
que vocês não usam e vocês continuam
comprando nem a gente continua nessa
girando essa carroça neste carrossel e
isso impacta na água dando o preço da
nossa conta de luz o preço da nossa
conta de água sem a gente parar muito
para pensar sobre isso
no ano são produzidos 80 milhões de
roupas peças de roupa 30% dessas peças
não são utilizadas
só que todas as roupas elas vêm da
natureza o algodão vem da natureza água
quer que a gente usa para lavar vem da
natureza é a gente utiliza os recursos
naturais que eles poderiam ser pra
comida para moradia para uma série de
coisas né produzindo roupas que as
pessoas não usam a 24 milhões de sobras
de roupa por ano é que dá esse número
30% só no bom retiro em são paulo 12
toneladas delas são descartadas por dia
de forma é desapropriada ou seja são
queimadas jogados em aterros sanitários
né isso enfim a gente não tem a menor
noção na índia 100 mil toneladas peças
são despejados por ano
a moda é a segunda indústria que mais
emite sec mais gastos e mais emite co2 é
a segunda que mais gasta a água é a
segunda que mais polui rios mares e
oceanos e um fazendeiro agricultor
suicida cada 30 minutos néné por dívida
ou por perda de colheita ou por doença
devido agrotóxicos é o produtos na acção
e forjado forjados para aumentar o tempo
para acelerar o tempo e 200 mil 200 mil
pessoas morreram nos 30 nos últimos 30
anos em bangladesh que é de onde sai a
maioria das roupas que a gente usa em
acidentes de trabalho em fábricas caíram
que pegaram fogo e taupo enfim é por
total de experiência dos donos das
fábricas né e vontade de cada vez mais
vender pelo menor preço enxugar a
estrutura enfim e escravizar e fazer
enfim uma série de coisas que
sabe o que acontece e isso me faz pensar
que a moda também perdeu o sentido
diante desse mundo que a gente vive hoje
né e que também a gente precise na moda
de uma grande virada assim como a gente
precisa no mundo
ah eu sou otimista apesar de todos esses
dados apesar de tudo isso que a gente é
que eu falei aqui que eu mostrei pra
vocês porque eu acho que hoje a gente
vive um momento de expansão da
consciência coletiva é cada vez mais
existem pessoas falando sobre isso que
eu tô falando ah vocês vão ver aqui veio
vê em muitos outros lugares você entrar
no facebook de vocês vocês vão ver
pessoas defendendo negros gays é enfim é
pessoas com uma acima do peso ou pessoas
com idade nana e política nem tão assim
cada vez mais as pessoas estão
entendendo o papel delas no mundo eu
observo muito isso e eu acho que isso é
o que vai provocar a transformação e
isso é o que vai provocar essa grande
virada na moda né o entendimento que
hoje existem questões a serem tratadas e
alternativas a serem tratadas né por
exemplo hoje comprar não é a única forma
mais que você pode ter acesso a uma peça
de roupa você pode trocar a pegar
emprestado nem novos modelos econômicos
novos modelos de transação e surgem né e
é importante considerar hoje toda a
questão ambiental em volta desse
processo de construção de uma roupa né
todas as questões sociais que têm a ver
com os funcionários empregados nem as
pessoas que compram e que fazem a sua
roupa e pensar em todos os padrões
culturais que a moda criou até hoje nem
relacionados à magreza beleza exclusão
social a poder há dinheiro há luxo é uma
série de coisas que só serviram para
frustrar cada vez mais pessoas não poder
com a cabeça de muita gente é atrapalhar
a vida de muita gente ea gente segue
fazendo isso como se fosse muito normal
como se fosse muito natural como se
fosse a coisa é mais legal do mundo não
foi sempre que eu pensei desse jeito eu
trabalho com moda há dez anos também é e
algum momento essa ficha começou a cair
pra mim e eu comecei a entender o olhar
essas coisas isso parou de fazer sentido
pra mim né e aí eu fui viajar eu fui pra
amazônia e eu fui na amazônia entender
como é que é feito couro e eu com ele
entende que hoje se não chove em são
paulo é por conta da bolsa de couro que
usava de sapato de couro que usava eu
fui para a índia
entender como é que moram lá e como é
que trabalham com essas pessoas é que
fazem a roupa que eu uso e aí eu fui
para o vale do silício na califórnia eu
fui entender né sobre novos modelos
econômicos nem sobre economia
colaborativa sobre economia
compartilhada e eu fui vendo que
realmente existem possibilidades uma vez
que a gente pare e que a gente pensa
sobre aquilo que a gente está fazendo e
aquilo que a gente está financiando
porque todo mundo aqui por mais que não
seja da indústria da moda compra roupa e
financia marcas né que sejam a favor ou
não da vida é que seja a favor ou não do
nosso planeta e eu cheguei à conclusão
de que o que falta na moda o que se
perdeu na moda ao longo dos últimos anos
foi o propósito é o propósito dela de
servir aos sonhos e de servir a
felicidade servir à vida das pessoas é
pra isso que a moda existe só que hoje
ela acabou se transformando né é na sua
grande maioria alguma coisa é muito ruim
alguma coisa de duvidosa e alguma coisa
é que não é tão legal né como um dia ela
já foi e eu passei a buscar o meu
propósito porque entende que somente
assim eu poderia chegar é e e retomar o
propósito da moda e aí pra mim passou a
não ter mais sentido trabalhar numa
grande marca e o abandonei meu trabalho
e passou a fazer muito sentido pra mim a
me envolver com pessoas que querem mudar
o mundo através da moda
e assim surgiu a malha que é hoje antes
já de nascer é o maior espaço de moda
colaborativa do brasil onde a nossa
ideia lhe é reinventar toda a cadeia e
trabalhar de forma colaborativa é de
forma é coletiva e recriar forma de se
pensar a moda de criar moda a de
produzir modo de comunicar à moda de
vender moda fazer tudo isso de um jeito
diferente né de um jeito coletivo então
enfim vocês podem ver mais sobre esse
projeto pela internet por aí e eu só
consegui chegar nesse ponto eu só
consegui fazer isso porque entendia que
a transformação ela precisava acontecer
em mim né eu ao longo desse tempo eu fui
trabalhando é com consultoria com outras
empresas e tentando compartilhar ou
criar projetos para em projetos para
empresas não é que falassem sobre
sustentabilidade e me formei em design
pela sustentabilidade para ter um
embasamento para isso e eu chegava nas
empresas eu falava e eu tentava e as
pessoas não valorizavam porque entende
que elas precisavam
as primeiras a se sensibilizarem com
isso né e enquanto isso não acontecer
enquanto a gente não sensibiliza a gente
não vai conseguir transformar nada a
gente não vai conseguir mudar nada ea
gente quando nasce a gente é muito livre
para tudo né a gente quer fazer qualquer
coisa da vida da gente sonha muito alto
a gente deseja muita coisa né a gente é
uma folha em branco mas aí a gente vai
crescendo ea gente vai vendo o
coleguinha do colégio a pessoa da escola
é o parente mais próximo a gente quer
ser daquele jeito ea gente entra no
colégio e o colégio uniformizar todo
mundo e diz que todo mundo tem que usar
a mesma roupa que todo mundo tem que
tirar a mesma média independentes e
melhor em matemática em português e
desse jeito a gente vai ser
uniformizando ea gente vai virando
iguais nessa seguidores né e aí quando
eu comecei a ter noção disso também eu
falei assim cara eu tenho que pegar leve
porque no meu primeiro livro cobro muito
que as marcas sejam autênticas e depois
eu parei pra pensar é muito injusto
cobrar isso porque desde que a gente
nasceu a gente estimuladas e cópia né
mas esse momento que a gente está
vivendo agora um momento que a gente
precisa abandonar todas as cópias
é um momento que a gente precisa
abandonar todos os padrões todas as
fórmulas todos os modelos já existentes
ea gente precisa inventar novos modelos
com uma nova cabeça com uma nova
filosofia com um novo pensamento né
tendo a certeza e tendo a consciência de
que o que a gente faz vai garantir o
nosso futuro o futuro das nossas
próximas gerações beleza e agora eu
queria propor uma coisa pra vocês
motivado pela shangai
eu tenho ainda que alguns minutinhos e
como eu falei eu acredito que toda
transformação ela precisa acontecer
dentro da gente primeiro né ea gente
para muito pouco para o olhar pra dentro
é pra escutar o que a gente
verdadeiramente quer então eu queria
propor que todo mundo agora convidar na
verdade quem quiser sentir à vontade é
querer pôr todo mundo fechasse os olhos
e que a gente fizesse um minuto de
silêncio e que com isso um minuto de
silêncio a gente pudesse não só aumentar
a vibração é de todo mundo que está aqui
né e assim é espalhar um sentimento uma
onda boa mas que durante esse tempo
vocês olharem para dentro e pensassem o
que realmente vocês gostariam de fazer
agora
vamos voltar e aí pode parecer uma
grande loucura né eu estou falando isso
aqui pra vocês é o que vem da moda eu
comecei aqui falando de moda e comecei a
falando de telefone e de computador né
mas de fato hoje e cada vez mais eu
acredito nisso assim é o mundo mudou e
vai continuar mudando e você já ouviu
hoje que mais de cem vezes as pessoas
que passarem por aqui falar isso mas
antes do mundo mudará enquanto o mundo
está mudando é a gente que precisa se
transformar e a gente só vai ver mudança
que a gente quer no mundo se a gente for
capaz de provocar alguma transformação
alguma mudança beleza
obrigado boa tarde a todos